what i want to do in this video is look
at the data from the last video and make
sure we understand it in maybe a more
visual way so what i've done is is in
this graph over here i used the lines of
code per month so this right over here i
used i used this or this was what i used
on my horizontal axis so i kind of if
you view it in terms of independent and
dependent variables i kind of made this
the independent variable now given a
certain number of lines of code you want
to produce per month what is the fixed
cost the variable cost and the total
cost so this is on this axis right over
here so this is lines of code
lines of code per month
per month right over there and then you
see it goes up to about 12 000 and we
see that covers the entire range of data
that we would have to worry about right
over here and on the vertical axis as i
just alluded to we are plotting the
costs so we're going to plot the fixed
cost of variable costs and the total
costs and we see that they're in our
little legend so the fixed costs no
matter how many lines of code we produce
and this is a little bit different than
the way we thought about in the last
video in the last video we said how many
programmers do we have and what is going
to be our fixed costs our variable cost
or total cost now we're thinking about
in terms of lines of code per month but
no matter how many lines of code per
month we produce within reason our fixed
costs are the same fifteen thousand
dollars per month for the office space
the food in the office the water cooler
the project manager things like that
and we see it right over here this pale
green line that is our fixed costs that
is our fixed cost no matter how many
lines of code we produce we are using
exactly fifteen thousand dollars per
month so this is fifteen thousand right
over there and then you have your
variable costs in this orange color so
the variable costs in the orange color
and we can see how the points are
plotted when you have no lines of code
per month your variable costs are zero
that's this point right over there when
you have 4 000 lines of code your
variable costs are ten thousand that's
that point right over there when you
have i can let me pick up a random point
over here when you have eleven thousand
four hundred lines of code per month
your variable costs are seventy thousand
eleven thousand four hundred let's see
this is about this is about eleven
thousand eleven thousand four hundred
and your costs are
seventy thousand dollars that's that
point right over there and then finally
your total cost or the sum of the fixed
plus the variable costs and we've
plotted this in this blue color
so the total cost
which is in blue right over here it's
really just the sum of this green
horizontal line and this orange line or
another way of thinking about it take
this orange line at any given point
that's the that's the variable cost add
the fixed cost which is fifteen thousand
it shifts you up to that blue line so at
any point the blue line is exactly is
exactly fifteen thousand dollars higher
fifteen thousand dollars higher than the
orange line you see it even over here
where it kind of bends back on itself
and then you're probably saying well why
is it bending back on itself like that
and this goes straight to what we talked
about in the last video that as we add
more and more programmers the average
productivity per programmer goes down
because they have to start meeting each
other and coordinate with each other and
maybe they undo each other's work and
then there's some point at which even
when you add more resources it actually
decreases productivity so we're adding
more and more resources and i don't have
them plotted here but we had keep we
keep adding more and more developers and
we get to this point where we're able to
make generate 11 400 lines of code per
month but then all of a sudden as we add
more developers it still adds cost
because obviously they're going to cost
something we have to pay their salaries
and their insurance and all of that but
then our total productivity starts going
down again and so that's what we're
seeing here when this when both the at
both the variable cost curve and our
total cost curve start start curving
back on itself now with this plotted
what i want to think about visually and
especially in terms of slope and i
encourage you to if though if the term
slope seems a little bit foreign to you
there's tons of videos on the idea of
slope and the algebra playlist
but the slope is really just how
inclined a line is so for example this
line has a higher slope than this line
right over there and that the way we
measure it is our change in our vertical
axis
so our change in our vertical axis often
given by change in y that triangles
that's the this delta greek letter delta
means change in y divided by our change
in divided by our change in our
horizontal axis that is change in x so
slope
is equal to change in y over change in x
and when you measure this way this line
over here it has looks like it has about
the same change in x but it has a much
lower change in y lower
lower change in y so when you take this
lower change in y divided by the same
change in x you're going to get a lower
slope and if you had a line that looked
like something like if you had a line
that looks something like this
then you have a much higher change in y
so your numerator is higher a higher
change in y and you have a lower change
in x and so your denominator is lower
that'll increase the value of the
quantity
so you're changing x so this right over
here is going to be a high slope
a high slope so without that with that
little primer out of the way on what a
slope is what i want to do is think
about
these average fixed cost average
variable cost average total cost and
marginal cost in terms of slopes of this
of these lines right over here so when
you're looking at average if we look at
this point right over here average fixed
cost
3.75 cents what that means is well when
we're producing 4 000 lines of code 4
000 lines of code our average fixed cost
is 3.75 so i'm on the green line
actually let me use a green color right
here i'm on this green line right over
here and to find that average so that's
our that is our that is our that is our
fixed cost and find our average fixed
cost we want to divide our fixed cost
which is
which is that height right over there
you want to divide it by the total lines
of code and that gives us our fixed
costs our average fixed cost per line of
code so we're taking we're taking a
change in the vertical axis divided by
our change in a horizontal axis right
there so it's essentially giving the
slope of this line just like that it's
giving the slope of that line and that's
this point right over here when you go
to this point right over here you're
saying okay i'm producing seven thousand
lines of code
and it still cost me it still cost me
fifteen thousand dollars that's fifteen
thousand dollars i divide my i divide my
total change in fixed costs divided by
my or my my total fixed cost divided by
my total
my total lines of code
divided by my total lines of code i'm
essentially getting the slope of
i know it's getting hard to see the way
i'm doing it i'm essentially giving you
the slope of let me draw a little bit
neater this line right over here and you
can see this line has a lower slope than
the previous one
and that makes sense because the average
fixed cost per line of code should be
going down we have the same fixed cost
and we're dividing it amongst more and
more and more code and you can see if
you go out here and you do the slope
from this point all the way over here
it's going to have even a little even a
lower slope so let me clear this out of
way so hopefully that makes sense the
fixed cost at least for me is maybe the
easiest to understand you're taking the
same quantity dividing it by more and
more code or by more and more developers
now the variable cost average variable
cost at any given point over here we're
taking the variable cost and we're
dividing it by the total amount of code
so variable costs
we it's over there it is it is ten
thousand dollars and we're dividing it
by four thousand lines of code so it is
the slope of this line right over here
when you go to 7000 lines of code you
say well my total variable cost is 20
thousand dollars and i'm going to divide
it by 7 000 lines of code so it is the
slope of this entire line right over
here i'm having trouble drawing these
lines it is the slope of this line right
over here and this is a curve so the
slope is different here than it is over
there this line what when we're
measuring the average variable cost
we're measuring you could imagine the
average slope across from the beginning
all the way to this point right over
here
now when you're doing the average total
cost you're doing the same thing average
total cost at that point is our total
total costs so it's that
divided by
the total code so the total code so it
is the slope of this line right over
there and we see that that slope it's
when you start over here when you start
when you start from this point to that
point the slope goes down but then we
see the slope start going it starts to
go up again because we saw that the
variables cost start increasing because
we get less and less efficiency as we
add more and more developers and attempt
at least to write more code now the
marginal cost is an interesting one all
of these other ones we're taking our
total cost our total variable cost our
total total cost our total fixed cost
and dividing by the total amount of code
so we're essentially finding the slope
of the line between these points and our
origin
when you're doing the marginal cost
you're doing something different and let
me clear all of this out so that we can
clear things up
your marginal cost is you're measuring
your change in total cost divided by not
your total total cost you're doing your
change in total cost divided by your
change in
the lines of code so for example that
right over let me do that in a more
vibrant color
that marginal cost
that's at this point right over here so
let's say we're gonna we could do it
with the we could do it with a variable
cost curve or we could do it with the
total cost curve i'll do it with the
total cost curve so it's this point
right over here so what we're doing is
we're doing we're taking the change in
total cost between the previous point
the previous point was there so our
change in total cost is just this part
right over here so this is our change in
total cost and we're dividing it by our
change in the amount of code we produce
so we're dividing it by the change in
change in lines of code so essentially
it's giving us the slope of the line
between the previous point and the
current point on the total cost curve
and we could do it so if we go right
over here let me go to another arbitrary
point that doesn't start from the
beginning so let's say we're looking at
this marginal cost so this was when we
were talking about 10 600 lines of code
and our total cost was 65 000
so our total cost is 65 000 10 600 lines
of code so that's that point right over
there
and what this is measuring it's our
change in total cost since the last
increment
so since the last increment since the
last point it's our change in total cost
it's our change in total cost divided by
the change in lines of code since the
last point
so the change of lines of code is just
that change in lines of code so our
marginal cost is that this quantity
divided by this quantity is the slope
between these two consecutive points so
what the marginal cost is giving us so i
just want to make sure we get everything
clear these average fixed average
variable average total cost that gives
us the slope of the line between any of
the points and the origin the marginal
cost is essentially giving us the slope
of the curve between any two consecutive
points on the total cost curve or you
could also view because it's really just
a shifted version of the variable cost
curve or you could view this as the same
as the slope of the line between any two
points on the variable cost curve so
this is this is an approximation you
could do this as the average and that's
why i wrote average over here this is
the average slope of the curve between
these two points